c'est une des rares activités à
l'extérieur pour brigitte paradis qui
depuis la pandémie sans le poids de la
routine en tant que célibataire en
bouche un peu en prenant deux sens n'a
qu' on se coiffe notre café ans déjà et
soit devenu je me permets pas en marche
tous les os cela fait maintenant un an
qu'elle s'est séparée de son conjoint
comment rend compte en temps de pandémie
sincèrement c'est pas évident à et
depuis quelques mois et le consultent
les sites et les agences de rencontre
c'est pas naturel ça on peut pas sortir
et peut-être de la star un sac à main ou
rencontrer après quelques festa et mes
textos et l'a décidé de rencontrer des
candidats non sans méfiance
à cause du virus choisel 2 mike pyle us
ce n'est pas grave ça la complexité pitt
et il n'y a pas de rapprochement
c'est un nom du maintien cette autre
dimension touche l'ensemble de
l'industrie de la rencontre amoureuse
parlez-en à muriel poitras qui gère son
agence en pleine pandémie
il ya eu une baisse de 50 pour sa tasse
et le massacre un corps sain avant les
confinements les activités organisées
pour ses clients étaient bien remplis
déjà les on se retrouve 40 45 personnes
c'est quand même agréable mais
maintenant qu'un vieux l'ouverture des
restaurants
c'était pas très très agréable avec la
distanciation il y avait pu l'être
cette belle grande taille lorsqu'on
s'assoit pour un échange pour certains
célibataires en temps de pandémie les
solitudes s'est encore amplifiée ils
sont seuls ya aucun endroit qui vous a
trompé rencontrer des gens et je pense
que la personne qui va traverser cette
pandémie l'heure c'est la personne qui
ont plus de facilité à accepter sa
solitude et de la côtoyer brigitte
paradis voie malgré tout du positif dans
cette époque rempli de méfiance data
management acquis et moi c'est moi je
sais quoi je veux faire c'est quoi ce
prêt tu as far as pas parfait la sagesse
en attendant que cupidon brise un jour
cette distanciation sociale
si frédéric arnould radio canada
montréal